this is what i do and um basically  running 10 miles a day 100 with a long  run on the weekends for 10 weeks prior  to a marathon i get a lot out of it that  accountability like provides me with  structure and and a sense of  accomplishment to start the day it's  like  the military guy who was given the um  commencement address and he said start  the day by making your bed you have one  win already that's how i view the run is  i if nothing else happens today i've  taken care of my most important asset my  mental and physical health  it's more important to me than  everything it has to be i can't be my  best self with my children or my wife  and i'm useless to anyone if i'm not  healthy this is just the reality of my  life is i just  maybe from the mistakes i've made and  the  the  things that i've been through like this  it's just what i need it is my  antidepressant